THE 50 MARK, THE I WILL LIT JUST
50,
HELLEBUYCK WILL SNARE THE LONG
SHOT FROM KK
AND THE CAOB GETTING
OFF TO THE RACES AND PROTECTS
IT.
LOOK AT THE WAY SPREADS HIS
LEGS.
HE KEEPS THAT BACK CHECK AT BAY
FROM ADAM LOWL.
THAT'S SECOND BEST IN THE NHL.
>> Dennis: SHOT FROM STONE
TURNED AWAYBENCH AND INTO THE FN
TKACHUK WILL DISH IT OFF.
TKACHUK IN FRONT.
SAVE MADE,CONNOR
HELLEBUYUY
JETS WINNING 4-2 INON HERE
MINNESOTA THE NIGHT GAME
BETWEEN THE JETS AND THE CALGARY
FLAMES HERE AT COT AS AN
INVESTMENT.
I LIKEFOR THE CALGARYN'T IT?
THIS MIGHT BE THE PLAY OF NIK
EHLERS' GAMEAL
AGAINST PHILADELPHIA A COUPLE
NIGHTS AGO TOSS
THE NET.
GREAT SE
>> OVERLOAD ON ONE SIDE FOR THE
FLAMES.
THEY GOT BURNT BDOWN.
PLAYS IT DOWN TO THE GOAL LINE.T
BREAK.
HOLDS THAT OFFENSIVE BLUE LINE
AND KEEPS THE PUWHEELER AND
BLACK FOR STASTNY AND BACK FOR
WHEELER.
HE LEAVES FOR EHLERS.
MAPS TO HELP YOU WITH THIS ONE.
BOPPING AND WEAVING ANDTASTNY.
>> Kevin: GOOD TO SEE THE
SMILE ON BLAKE'S FACE.
HE DOESN'T OFTEN -- KIND OF
WHERE IS THE PUCK ON ROUTE TWO.
THERE'S LOWRY ABOVE THE PLAY.
HE KEEPS IT
WATCH THIS.
LOOK AT THE ANGLE.
NOTHING TO WORK  THE FORECHECK.
GETS IN AT THE LINE.
MORRISSEY THE PUCK.
REBOUND.
ORRISSEY,
THOUGH.
A NICE LITTLE JUMP.
KYLE CONNOR AT THE HT ARM THEREE
LOOKS.
DUBOIS TO THE FRONT OF THE NET.
BRENDEN DIN THE EARLY PART OF TS
SHIFT, AND IT'S HIS THIRD SHOT
AND KYLE CONNOR, N
>> THIS IS GOOD, AGGRESSIVE
QUICK SKILLED HOCKEY HERE FROM
THE
IT STARTED.
>> Dennis: THE INABILITY TO 20-.
SITTING ON 16.
HARKINS, AND VLADAR WILL ATE SM.
BRANDON TANEV
ONE-TIMER.
PIONK UNLOADS.
LOOSE PUCK AND DOWN THE  AN EXCS
TKACHUK WHO